[Music]
i want to begin chris by apologizing i
think at the top of the show i said
gethard and then someone said no it's
get third am i pronouncing it you are
you can pronounce it any way you want as
long as you don't pronounce it
phonetically which is get
hard g-e-t h-a-r-d something told me not
to do that yeah something deep in my
mind yes it's it's rough it's not easy
the worst part of that was junior high
school that was not good really having
imagined kids sort of they jumped on
they picked up on that quite fast yeah
quite quickly the worst part though is
my family has a real bad habit they
can't pick first names that don't make
it worse like this is not a joke my
grandfather's name was les
get hard
and he named my father my father's first
name is kenneth his name is ken gethard
and uh
that's better than les gether it is it
is i'd rather be can get her but my dad
told me a couple years ago i'm now at
the age where i can like talk with my
dad about stuff like this and he's like
well i worked hard to make sure you and
your brother didn't have it
that curse and i said well you named him
gregory kennedy so he's greg can get
hard
christopher paul so i'm c paul get hard
you made sentences you made sentences
out of them
i have to make paragraphs
they avoided richard yeah yeah
that's the obvious yeah yeah yeah
i've thought about amanda like amanda
yeah yeah
there's all sorts of puns so uh so this
has just made your life miserable i mean
i was named i i i i'm conan i had a
better thanking god for that right now
right better than see paul get hard
yes i feel better now yeah
i'm glad i came here today now i feel
better yeah they called me get hard and
also mega head mega head was awesome
because of this
you've got a prominent uh brow yes yes
my whole life i've just been mocked
that's it that's it so nice to meet you
by the way yeah
it's nice to meet you too glad to be
here
well uh listen you're you're putting it
to good use which is yes you've had a
rough childhood rough life you've been
mocked now you have a very unusual
public access show and it's becoming
very uh popular on the web with the
youngsters why don't you tell us what
it's about describe your show because
it's very strange it is it's very weird
it's very unusual but i like it i think
it has a good heart you can watch it all
online we got a lot of great people got
the world's greatest dancer rob malone
we got the human fish we got a guy named
phil jackson not the basketball coach a
different guy named phil jackson this
last week we did a show on wednesday
where i was blindfolded the whole time
and i didn't know what was going on so
the next day i watched the show and only
then did i realize that my friend drew
was dressed as a horse using a fishing
pole to dangle a two-foot long sausage
in front of my face the whole show
the entire time so that's our show it's
really smart comedy i salute you thank
you thank you you're in the comedy
you're in a good place thank you thank
you you're doing everything i believe in
now you have a um you've tried to
establish i think kind of an honest and
maybe leaving a little bit unusual
relationship with your fans is that
right we let them call us during the
show and say whatever they want they can
tweet at us during the show it all shows
up on the screen and i answer the emails
i got the best email i've ever gotten
about the show this past week this kid
emailed me he goes i'm 13 i live in
ottawa i just found your show i really
love it i think it's amazing that
there's a show that's okay with being
both unfunny and at times painfully sad
i like that
it made me feel like we were nailing it
that kid really guess what we're going
for
again i salute you thank you you're a
real inspiration thank you thank you
glad i'm glad i could help you the crew
was particularly happy about a bit that
you did that involved a kickboxer yeah
we have a piece of tape just describe
what this is sure some friends of mine
came on the show they gave us facts
about their lives i had to guess which
fact applied to which person if i got it
wrong i was punished there's many
physical punishments i'm often
physically beaten on my own show
this is an example of one of those bits
and how it turned out and you you used a
real kickbox this guy is a trained muay
thai kickboxer let's take a look at this
clip
uh from uh from the chris gethier show
all of the people on the panel and in
our band tonight have submitted facts
about their lives it will be my job to
match the fact to the person and if i
get it wrong it means i'm a bad friend
and what i deserve
is a legitimate kickboxer
giving me a body shot i was once
arrested for skinny dipping i'm going to
guess bethany
[Music]
that's a real
it's not good
again we're just going to rip that off
uh
and that was a body shot no but that
looks like it really hurt though it was
the worst physical pain i've ever been
in my entire life by far
by far but it got a laugh
marginally it got a margin until next
week's show